one of the things I think is really
important for all of us to be able to do
is to figure out when we see a headline
when we start seeing something enter the
discussion and get repeated over and
over again and it's a major claim we
need to be able to figure out for
ourselves is it backed by evidence or is
this disinformation or misinformation
and we have the perfect example today
there's a new I'm I'm going to use some
of the words they're using even though
they're BS quite frankly there's a new
quote study
about covet vaccines from quote Florida
floating around
which I started seeing over the weekend
during my live streams I saw some of the
people in the chat saying David new
study from Florida says that covet
vaccines increase heart attacks by 84
percent in the month after one is
vaccinated when you get a vaccine
your odds of a heart attack go up 84
percent for the month after you've
received that vaccine so the first
question with all of these things is
does it pass the sniff test so with some
of these things you know uh it turns out
we don't breathe oxygen we actually
breathe
um really light water you know so I
don't know we would say this doesn't
even pass the sniff test it's not really
even worth looking into now let's
imagine it were true that getting a
coveted vaccine increases your chances
of a heart attack by 84 percent we would
be talking about so many heart attacks
heart attacks and deaths that we would
have heard about this more more quickly
than two years into vaccination but
let's imagine that we want to take this
seriously and explore it the source of
this is Florida's Surgeon General Joseph
ladapo a known anti-vaccine voice and
ours Technica has a really good write-up
about the so-called analysis and he put
out a statement on Friday that men age
18 to 39 should not get the covid
vaccine why not well he claims to have
an analysis called exploring the
relation relationship between all cause
and cardiac related mortality following
covid-19 vaccination or infection in
Florida residents a self-controlled case
series study there is then a press
release about the analysis so now we're
like a layer removed now it's a press
release about an analysis the press
release says coveted vaccines cause an
84 percent increase in the relative
incidence of cardiac related death among
males 18 to 39 within 28 days following
mRNA vaccination there's a lot of
important data in that claim or
important metrics in that claim which we
are going to look at so let's take a
look at the analysis one of the things
you might notice when you pull up the
analysis is it's supposedly from the
Florida Department of Health but it's
not on Florida Department of Health
letterhead that's sort of weird for an
analysis supposedly from the Florida
Department of Health there's no authors
listed on the study well that's really
weird and of course it's not peer
reviewed
obviously I mean is that there's not
even a claim that it is or that it's in
any journal or that that has been
reviewed in any way so what is the
analysis that has been done well the
first thing is they did what's called a
self-controlled case series
we're going to talk about what that is
how should we look at vaccine safety you
would want to take a group of vaccinated
people and a group of not vaccinated
people maybe they get a placebo the
non-vaccinated people so no one even
knows whether they are or aren't
vaccinated you match them up
demographically so that in both of these
groups you have similar underlying
health statuses other parameters age Etc
and you compare them over a period of
time which of the groups over a period
of time the vaccinated or unvaccinated
group has more infections or more cancer
or more car accidents whatever and the
idea is you want to make vaccination the
only variable one group has the vaccine
the other doesn't and they are otherwise
identical groups in a self-controlled
case series which is what was done
there's no control group the only people
in their study
um are the people that
um are being studied and whose outcomes
are being measured there's no control
group it's uh you know you've got a
coveted vaccine died within 25 weeks and
then they look subsequently at the group
that died within the first four weeks
and what they wanted to see was are the
deaths clustered in the first four weeks
after the vaccination which is
considered the risk period for a vaccine
during which a side effect or a
complication could happen and so they
they look at the first four weeks and
then they call weeks 5 to 25 the control
group that doesn't make sense that's not
good science and I'm getting so wound up
that I punched my microphone now what
they also did was they excluded people
from the study
who had coveted died of covid and they
excluded people with boosters
why would you do that wait a second you
want to study something related to covid
and the vaccine you have no control
group and you exclude people from the
study who had coveted died of covet or
had a booster meaning they went beyond
their first two-dose regimen well that's
nonsense that doesn't make sense they
also don't actually have any medical
information for cause of death they only
have death certificates and as we know
death certificates through no deliberate
attempt at fraud don't always represent
the heart of the matter for lack of a
better term about how someone died
sometimes you die because of a
complication from covid that
complication goes on the birth
certificate but not the fact that you
had covid and the reason you were in the
hospital was coveted and then a
complication came up just as one example
they don't know how many people died of
undocumented covet cases after one dose
of the vaccine for example where one
dose of the vaccine is not considered
that you are protected
that's not actually a full regimen even
the cardiac related causes of death
might not be the analysis says in it
quote cardiac related deaths were
ascertained if a code of
i3152 was on the death certificate thus
the underlying cause of death may not be
cardiac related they're even saying some
of these cardiac related deaths might
not really be cardiac related they also
didn't separate out people with mRNA
vaccines and non-mrna in a clean-cut way
they claim to be studying the effects of
mRNA vaccines remember the Johnson and
Johnson vaccine is not an mRNA vaccine
they have two classifications they have
people with an mRNA vaccine and people
with a non-mrna or unknown type of
vaccine
you could have obvious misclassification
when those are your categories and it
also only looked at men 18 to 39 now
there's two important things about that
first of all they combined 18 to 24 and
25 to 39 why would they do that
when the underlying data separates those
into two groups 18 to 24 25 to 39 why
would you combine them well they don't
say and of course the speculation is
that by combining those two groups you
get them the finding that they wanted
this is a version of What's called the P
hacking Google p hacking and and you'll
very quickly learn what that is last
thing the number of deaths in the
specific group they studied was 20.
during the first four weeks and then 52
in the so-called control period 5 to 25
weeks and the sample sizes are so small
and it's not really a control group that
the data are essentially meaningless so
don't fall for it
Joseph ladapo should be more concerned
with disease outbreak in Florida
following the hurricane and power
outages which is a real issue after a
natural disaster uh than putting
together these bogus so-called analyzes
messing with the data no control group
wrong type of study on and on and on so
when you see the headline now vaccines
cause 84 increase in cardiac death
you now are equipped to understand that
the so-called analysis is completely
bogus we got some very interesting news
yesterday about the American
relationship with Saudi Arabia if you've
been listening to this show for a while
if you've been watching the show for a
while you know that I have been saying
for what a decade and a half the United
States really needs to reevaluate its
relationship with Saudi Arabia now we
understand why the relationship exists
there is a sort of General shared
interest in calm in the Middle East
between the United States and Saudi
Arabia and this relates to oil prices
and oil production and for other reasons
and that has been a major factor in the
relationship between the U.S and Saudi
Arabia a cut to the New York Times
yesterday Joe Biden vows consequences
for Saudi Arabia after oil production
cut
the article reads angered by the
Kingdom's decision to team up with
Russia President Biden signaled openness
to retaliatory measures including a halt
to arm sales and allowing price fixing
lawsuits this is a very good article in
the Times by Peter Baker and it reads
that Biden vowed yesterday to impose
consequences on Saudi Arabia signaling a
rupture in the relationship between two
longtime allies and a reversal of
Biden's own effort to cultivate the
energy-rich Kingdom this all relates to
last week's decision by saudi-led OPEC
uh OPEC plus a Biden staff announced he
would quote re-evaluate the entire
relationship with Saudi Arabia and
expressed openness to retaliatory
measures offered by Congressional Dems
such as curbing arms sales or permitting
legal action against the cartel this is
as much about the direct relationship
with Saudi Arabia as it is about the
Russian war in Ukraine and we have to
see whether these are empty empty words
or not are these empty threats are these
just vague promises that will never
become anything or is this something
real again
I did not have particularly high hopes
for Joe Biden when
I decided I would support him over
Donald Trump he was the obviously
correct decision over Donald Trump for
any sane person even remotely Tethered
to reality but my expectations were
quite muted about Joe Biden and despite
a period of about three or four months
five or six months maybe even during
which very little that I could point to
and say this is a good thing has
happened Joe Biden's presidency has
really uh sort of taken a turn for the
better and it would be another great
thing from my perspective if Joe Biden
were to reevaluate this relationship
consider the reality of Saudi Arabia I
mean first of all
funded 911 most hijackers were Saudi
killed and dismembered Saudi journalist
Jamal khashoggi there has been
essentially no accountability war in
Yemen with massive human rights abuses
by the way I mean with some American
support the United States hands are not
exactly clean of blood there either
um important to measure to mention
state-sponsored
Theocratic misogyny and depression
although it has improved slightly over
the last 10 years
economically supporting Russia in their
war in Ukraine this has been an alliance
for oil purposes and for general
interest and stability in the Middle
East purposes and in particular with the
United States I mean listen is it as
fast to move away from fossil fuels as I
would like no not nearly but in
particular with the growing priority of
the United States under Joe Biden much
more so than under Donald Trump of
furthering alternative and renewable
energy usage and getting away from
fossil fuels
there is less of a need in a sense to be
cozy with what is a very backwards
dictatorial state so if we were able to
detach ourselves from the I guess we'll
call it the teat of Saudi oil it's a
good thing long term now the truth is
that the global situation is much more
complicated that I'm making it out to be
in this segment there are many other
considerations there are all sorts of
triangles in which you have the United
States and Saudi Arabia and some other
country which are important
considerations as well from a foreign
policy standpoint but it would be one of
the greatest things Joe Biden could do
to cool that relationship off it's been
something I've been calling for for a
very long time now in the short term the
problem is that this action by Saudi
Arabia will cause Energy prices to go up
and if Joe Biden did indeed take some
substance of substantive step to cool
that relationship and to reevaluate it
will probably cause energy prices to go
up even more and we're getting into
winter where home Energy prices are an
important thing the increase in in
Energy prices will almost certainly be
used against Joe Biden in 2024
Republicans will be able to say listen
Biden chose to do this with Saudi Arabia
and this made everybody's home energy
costs more and gas price there's no
doubt that Republicans will try to do
that
it's easy to say well it's worth it
anyway well for some people it's an
extraordinarily difficult situation to
have an increase in gas prices or home
Energy prices home heating prices Etc
that will be an effect and it will be
they will try to use it against Joe
Biden
at some point the decision has to be
made to back away from this absolutely
horrifying relationship with Saudi
Arabia and I always say there's no
better time than the present if you
disagree with me let me know you can
find me on Twitter at dpacman and we'll
be back after this very short break
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com and use the coupon
code better 21 for a huge discount
joinpakman.com
the David packman show is an audience
supported program different than
corporate media our primary funding
source is people who listen to the show
people who watch the show and to that
end I would love for you to get a
membership at joinpakman.com we do an
extra show every day for our members
called the bonus show Alex Jones hates
the bonus show oh the bonus show where
you want to make money everybody else
that makes money to fund themselves is
bad well yeah make money in order to
fund the show Alex there's nothing wrong
with that you can use the coupon code
big
voting22 to get yourself a tidy little
discount off of the cost of membership
you also get the show without
commercials six hours before everybody
else every single weekday pretty good
perk I must say joinpakman.com
many of you have been asking the
question what the hell happened to the
Republican Party
it can be difficult to notice changes
sometimes when those changes happen
slowly
let's take a look at how the Republican
party has changed over a longer period
of time and then talk about exactly how
it happened I am going to play a clip
for you here of William F Buckley
talking with Noam Chomsky in 1969. now
when you do a progressive show there is
no conservative that you can put up as
an example that your your left-wing
audience in this case my left-wing
audience will agree yeah this is an
example of sort of like normal
conservatism and we disagree with
conservatism I understand that now I
know many of you will say David
Buckley's a loser he was a pompous
condescending clown okay Buckley had a
set of principles he argued them what I
would consider by today's standards
respectfully he stood for something he
engaged with people with whom he
disagreed
check this out this was one flavor of
conservatism and the Republican Party in
the late 60s and it lasted into the 70s
into the early 80s okay here's William F
Buckley talking with Noam Chomsky right
so but you also say that you hate
yourself for not having come to that
position uh earlier yeah I do I think
that's a very great great mistake well I
hope to give you a little Solace
the reason I do raise this and I rejoice
in your disposition to argue the Vietnam
question especially when I recognize
what an act of self-control this must uh
involve it does sure it really does I
mean I think that there's a good kind of
issue really very well sometimes I lose
my temper Maybe not maybe not tonight
uh because if you would I'm smashing the
goddamn thing
you said you say in your reason for not
losing you say the war is simply an
obscenity a depraved act by weak and
miserable men including all of us
including myself including every that's
the next sentence
because you count everybody in the
company of the guilty I think that's
true yeah
okay so anyway these are really
interesting debates and conversations
that was like what the Republican Party
one part of it right we can find wacky
examples as well but you could talk to
these people okay these they operated in
something that approached reality
here are some examples of the modern
Republican party not only do we do have
the DC jail which is the DC gulag
Pelosi get
s respond on the legislative work that
we do gazpacho police that's
congresswoman Marjorie Taylor green
here is another example of the modern
Republican Party
for Senator Ted Cruz but but I will tell
you tonight it is the coolest thing I've
ever heard about yeah about Ted Cruz
there you go that's a radical republican
congresswoman Lauren bobert and then of
course the modern Republican Party
numerous categories were lower than the
world lower than towards Europe and what
look and what take a look
right here
's case death
oh you're doing death as a proportion of
cases I'm talking about death as a
proportion of population that's where
the US is really bad well much worse
than South Korea Germany Etc you can't
you can't do that you have why can't you
have to go by
you have to go by where look here is the
United States you have to go by the
cases the cases why not as a
proportional population somebody what it
says is when you have somebody that has
where there's a case oh okay the people
that deliver from those cases all right
that's a major contrast okay point I
think Point made now you could say well
but you know the modern Republican party
also has people like Mitt Romney in it
uh yeah how much attention do they get
they have been pushed to the fringes
so how did this happen and this is the
story that I've told before in fact when
when I interviewed Noam Chomsky we
talked about this story whatever you
think about Noam Chomsky I'm just saying
there's a discussion about this story in
that interview
and the path is more or less as follows
from the William F Buckley clip to what
I just played for you from from the the
orange Menace
the Civil Rights era
set off
a period of extreme uh instability in
the American right where many in the
American right did not like what the
Civil Rights era brought when they talk
about their world view we say it sort of
sounds like they want to go back to the
1950s that's exactly right before the
Civil Rights era which started you know
you could argue 58 or different people
would put it at a different point that
and the attempt to level the playing
field in many ways
started to anger much of the right where
not William F Buckley but others started
to get away from what we might now
called that principled conservatism of
of a certain point uh through the
Vietnam War
and into the Reagan Era we saw this
shift into what we might call more kind
of like meme politics from the right
uh actor Ronald Reagan
comes up with stuff like you know the
Cadillac driving welfare mom and and
starting to make these caricatures of
people hanging out living richly on
welfare
and on and on although Reagan was still
sort of reasonable compared to the
modern Republican party on something
like immigration but that was just one
step we then go from Reagan and I'm
condensing the story to Bill Clinton
knocking out one term making George H.W
bush a one-term president which in 1992
significantly angered many in the
Republican party to then Newt Gingrich
becoming Speaker of the House in 1994 in
the 1994 midterms that was the next
escalation
it's not even really an escalation it's
like if you have
rhetoric on one side and policy on the
other
it continued the shift of the Republican
party from policy to rhetoric Newt
Gingrich in 1994 starting to develop the
more cartoonish social conservative
starting to get a little bit more
detached from policy then when you had
the Clinton Lewinsky scandal it
escalated what we could probably call
Clinton derangement syndrome Kenneth
Starr's investigation
Etc and then it set the stage for the
first what I would call the modern kind
of like dumb Republican George W bush
now George W bush I'm sure personally
he's a nice guy and in some of the he
has been more thoughtful in some of the
statements he's made publicly since
leaving office particularly over the
last five to six years but George W bush
with his made-up words and confusion
about foreign policy and all these
things ushered in the first kind of like
you know
light would intellectually lightweight
uh in the more Modern Way movement in
the Republican party then Barack Obama
won and it just Unleashed and even you
you took the bush contingent or
constituency and added some overt racism
and that was the next escalation and
then of course then ultimately we got to
Trump that's the path that's the 40 50
year path and it's really important to
understand it when we think about how we
got from William F Buckley to Donald
Trump right the guy who's staring at a
solar eclipse and saying what about
injecting bleach it's a sad decline
and it's unclear where the Republican
party goes next but it's good to know
how we got here let's now talk about the
possible outcomes to the 2022 midterm
election there are four possible
outcomes to the midterms that are now
just a few weeks away
three of the outcomes are really pretty
bad so let's explore what these outcomes
are we have control of the house up for
grabs and control of the Senate up for
grabs if we look at the latest 538
forecasts uh Democrats are by a roughly
two to one margin favorite to win the
Senate okay roughly by a two to one
margin favor to win in the Senate and if
you look at the House Republicans are by
a greater than two to one margin favored
to win the house so if we want to put
numbers to this there's a roughly 70
percent chance that Republicans win the
house and of roughly 67 chance that
Democrats win the Senate so you
essentially have four possible outcomes
imagine a two by two grid Democrats
could win both the House and Senate
Republicans could win both the House and
Senate you could have Democrats win the
house but lose the Senate you could have
Democrats win the Senate but lose the
house those are the four scenarios so
let's do some simple probability math
these should add up to 100 these are the
four possible outcomes and we're going
to do these in order of likelihood and
then you have the following
based on the 538 projections the the
most likely outcome is Democrats win the
Senate and Republicans win the house
that's 46 percent you've got a 24 chance
that the Republicans win both you've got
a 20 chance that Democrats win both and
then you've got a 10 chance that
Democrats win the house but Republicans
win the Senate that's the least likely
outcome so let's start with the least
likely and work up
if Democrats win the house and
Republicans win the Senate it's not
going to happen but it would mean that
Democrats pass a ton of stuff in the
house that Joe Biden wants and basically
none of it gets past the Senate it's a
done deal it's really good for
republicans in 2024 they can say look
um they had the house and the White
House they proposed nothing reasonable
the senate had to block the stuff they
wanted to do vote for republicans in
2024. okay next scenario is that
Democrats win both this is the best
outcome quite frankly there's only a 20
percent chance of that now in this
scenario the Senate margin is not 60 40
meaning that it remains like the last
two years a lot of stuff you need 60
votes in order to pass so Democrats if
they held both the House and Senate
would be able to get some things done
Republicans would have struck them the
senate for everything that requires 60
votes they would claim these Democrats
are so extreme in what they propose we
have no choice choice
next scenario in order of likelihood
going up is Republicans take the house
and the Senate now that's also not the
most likely scenario it's obviously
disastrous nothing will get done for two
years if Republicans take both they will
try to blame Biden even though it is
their obstruction that will prevent
anything from getting done they will say
we had no choice everything Biden and
the Democrats put forward was so extreme
that we had to block it it will give
them a good setup for 2024 including to
actually try to influence the election
Itself by all sorts of subterfuge and
arguably illegal means the most likely
outcome of plurality is that Democrats
win the Senate and Republicans win the
house there's a nearly 50 percent chance
of that particular individual result
in that scenario Republicans will stop
things in the house Democrats will
control the Senate but will have no
super majority and it will mean that
almost nothing happens Biden will be
blamed Democrats will be blamed and then
Republicans will use it to their
advantage in 2024.
so what has to happen
obviously we should not concede the
house but the math of it is very much
not in the favor of Democrats so the
scenario
that is the most likely is Democrats
keep the Senate by a small margin but
lose the house
what we need to see is some of the
gubernatorial races go to the Democratic
candidate because ultimately you are
going to have I believe very little
accomplished during the next two years
thanks to Republicans taking the house
and then you will have a 2024 election
which may come down to governors in key
States potentially stealing electoral
votes Pennsylvania is a huge issue where
Josh Shapiro has to beat off a challenge
from Doug mastriano who he will try to
steal the Pennsylvania electoral votes
for the Republican nominee we know that
so Josh Shapiro's got a win in
Pennsylvania in Arizona this radical big
lie purveyor Kerry lake is currently
winning by a little bit Arizona is
another important state where if you
have a republican governor who is a full
big lie proponent
she may try to steal the Arizona
electoral votes for the Republican
candidate even if they don't actually
win the popular vote in that state so I
believe that the most likely scenario
here is Democrats keep the Senate lose
the house and the next two years will
ultimately conclude with do Democrats
control enough Governor's houses
that they can prevent the theft of the
2024 election if the Democratic
candidate is to win it's also possible
that the next two years are so
disastrous that a Republican president
legitimately wins in 2024. we can't deal
with that now what we can deal with is
who do we vote for in just three and a
half weeks I think roughly three two and
a half weeks three and a half weeks and
these are the four scenarios let me know
your thoughts we will have this and all
of our other Clips on our Instagram
which you can find at davidpackman show
if you value what we do at the David
packman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com davidpackman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos The Daily bonus show
the commercial free Daily Show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show there have
been some outtakes released from this
stunning interview that Kanye West did
with Fox News propaganda Tucker Carlson
that are so insane and so anti-semitic
that they raise a whole new series of
questions about Kanye's seeming
obsession with the Jews or Jew as he
sometimes refers to them this is super
interesting so over the last week
there's been a lot happening with
um a musical artist Kanye West test
wherein he showed up in Europe with a
white lives matter shirt
and then he appeared with Tucker Carlson
and talked about how great Trump is and
it was like really a very kind of
fawning interview of course because
Kanye West has become useful to the
right and then he ended up getting
suspended from multiple social media
platforms for uh basically just going on
an anti-semitic tirade and attacking
Jews and saying I think Diddy is
controlled by Jews and all this
different stuff
vice's motherboard that's the source for
these clips has now uncovered
clips from the Tucker Carlson interview
that were cut from what was broadcast
and they are absolutely and utterly
insane and we're going to look at a
couple of these and I what I want to
mention to people is
I think my audience mostly knows I'm
Jewish
I have had
experiences with anti-semites of every
flavor casual anti-semites who just
unthinkingly have attached themselves to
the very easy tropes you know oh Jews
are cheap that's one I dealt with with
other employees when I worked at Circuit
City I've recently tweeted about that
there's also the sort of more
conspiratorial people about an elitist
cabal Bilderberg Rothschild you know
this sort of stuff then there's also the
black Israelites which we're going to
get into in a moment there's all sorts
of these different flavors and some
people are just obsessed with Jews they
look at Jews as the sole cause of
everything that is bad uh on our planet
okay let's get into the first clip in
this is an outtake okay
Kanye says that the founder of Planned
Parenthood
uh created Planned Parenthood with the
KKK to control the Jew population and
again this one you could say this one is
not overtly anti-semitic but it's all
part of the obsession with Jews check
this out let's go to the first one
Planned Parenthood was made by Margaret
Sanger
a known Eugenics with the KKK
to control
the Jew population when I say Jew I mean
the 12 lost tribes of Judah the blood of
Christ who
the race the people known as the race
black really are this is who our people
are yeah this is this is super confusing
so try to follow along the blood of
Christ this as a Christian is my belief
and I believe that if we saw ourselves
as more
yeah
so
first of all Margaret Sanger
early sort of women's rights and Family
Planning Advocate uh was Jewish as far
as my research revealed so the idea that
she wanted to control the Jew population
I don't really know what Kanye means
control it by lowering it or boosting it
I don't know this is all completely
Bonkers now when Kanye talks about
the race black are the real Jews I know
some in my audience already know about
this and some don't there is a movement
called the black Israelites or the
Hebrew Israelites it is a movement that
goes back to the late 1800s where some
mostly Pentecostal black Christians
started to claim that in a revelation
they learned they were the true Hebrews
you can find examples of the term
Hebrews Israelites the real Jews
whatever
generally speaking this is a pretty
racist movement in the modern day they
claim that Jews are sort of devilish
imposters and that the real Jews are
black folks okay
um
let's let's leave it there
was another clip in which Kanye used a
weird metaphor
and then brings up the Jews again in the
metaphor and then asks for it to be cut
from the interview to which you'll
notice Tucker Carlson says done when
Kanye says I want that cut out Tucker
says done this also is interesting
because it exposes that more than likely
part of the agreement for this interview
was Kanye has sort of like final edit
and can ask for anything to be cut how
common that is on Tucker Carlson's show
I don't know I've never given that to
anybody on our program exactly what our
culture is based on think about us
judging each other on how white we could
talk would be like
you know
a Jewish person judging another Jewish
person on how good they danced
or something I mean that's probably like
a bad uh as I don't know if people gonna
get mad at that but
uh
uh another thing that they do
um
that I probably want to edit that out
they're probably not like that done
Tucker says consider it done Kanye
you're producing here okay so
you know I was talking to Ice Cube Today
and we got really beat up in 2020 for
saying we need to approach things a
different way and not just be trauma
drunk right which is a term that I you
know God okay so again the example he
tries to go to is something about Jews
obsessed with Jews realizes it's going
nowhere and then asks for it to be cut
out a small note here Kanye did say
during the interview that he's
vaccinated that was cut out from the
final cut that aired I don't think that
was Kanye's request that seems to be a
Fox News decision no every day we've
been killing each other
in the streets
every day one of the amazing things with
uh mayor Suarez is the the murder rate
has gone down and yeah I don't I mean
you set that question up you have more
information about the uh
about the uh about what happened in the
hospitals so in all honesty I don't I
don't have the the most facts as
manufacturing I mean in your life like
so I might have done vaccine the being
stuck inside like what did you think of
all that I was I was vaccinated it was
interesting a friend of mine so I was
vaccinated was removed from the Final
Cut and then lastly here just again the
continued obsession with Jewish people
and in this one he does the
um sort of sort of like money Trope
where he says he would rather his kids
know about Hanukkah rather than Kwanzaa
because it'll come with some Financial
engineering and again this is the the
idea that Jews control the financial
system and this is one of the oldest
anti-semitic claims around and and
Kanye's full in on it listen to this
listen how casually he mentions this too
biting my tongue on my political opinion
because I thought it would be better for
my children and now you look up and my
kids are going to a school that teaches
black kids a complicated Kwanzaa
I prefer my kids new Hanukkah than
Kwanzaa at least it will come with some
Financial engineering
Kwanzaa doesn't you know so
um and by the way I can tell you at
Hanukkah nobody talks to you about IRAs
or compounding interests it's just not
it's not where I ever learned about that
stuff he's obsessed with Jewish people
and I have seen people like this there
are folks who get fixated on
particular things and sometimes it's you
know the hammer that turns everything
into a nail for them is Jews sometimes
it's you know uh the trilateral
commission sometimes it's geoengineering
or control through fluoride in the water
system or whatever the case may be
Fox News has sort of backed off with a
number of segments in the last 24 hours
saying the interview the White lives
matter thing is interesting
but all the Tweet the anti-semitic
tweets that's too far Maria Bartiromo
for example and others and they're
chalking this up to mental illness and
again
sure mental illness can be a factor but
most mentally ill people don't become
obsessed with the Jews really Bonkers
stuff from Kanye and I find it all to be
completely horrible hey here's something
kind of I don't know that that it's
funny but it's certainly interesting
somehow uh Georgia Republican Senate
candidate Herschel Walker managed to do
another press event and at this event he
was joined by Republican Senators Tom
Cotton and Rick Scott two horrible
people
Walker did his normal routine where he
tells unintelligible stories in an
incoherent way and you can visibly see
cotton and uh Scott cringing where they
clearly seem to be thinking what the
hell am I doing here I don't know who
thinks these events are good ideas here
is Herschel Walker railing against
pronouns
um I'm going to take a position against
adverbs if I ever run for something but
Walker focused on pronouns and just look
at the looks on cotton and Scott's faces
trying to act as though this is normal
when they clearly know it is not hey
just think about it pronoun in our
military
how do you identify in our military This
Is War times what happened to push-ups
sit-ups
and tell you right now
China I ran to Russia not talking about
pronouns right Tom Cotton looking
particularly pained as this is going on
here is another one of Herschel Walker's
great stories about a bear and a dog and
something about how he's responding to
the abortion scandal
they'll do whatever it takes but say
whatever they have to say because they
want this seat right here
but I don't think they know that they
woke up a bear right
hey I'm not just a dog now I'm a bear
yeah and I got a couple email from some
of our viewers in the LGBT community
saying does he understand what bears are
in the LGBT community I'm sure he
doesn't uh and then last clip here
Herschel Walker again tries telling the
story
about the Bulls and the cows in the
field every time he tells the story the
story is different and again here Rick
Scott looking particularly demoralized
at having to stand up there
as they've been saying something is
better somewhere else and I'm here to
tell you it's not so I've been telling
this little story about this bull out in
the field with six cows right and three
of them are pregnant
so you know he got something going on
but all he cared about is kept his nose
against the fence looking at three other
cows have been blown to him
now all he had to do is eat grass but no
no no he thought something was better
somewhere else so he decided I want to
get over there so one day he imagined
that fence up
and you say I think I can jump this
so that they came where he got back
and he got back and as he took off
running he Dove over that fence and his
barely got cut up onto the bottom but as
he made it over on the other side he
shook it off and got and got so excited
about it and he ran to the top of that
hill but when he got up there he
realized they were Bulls too
so what I'm telling you
don't think something is better
somewhere I think that maybe this is a
version of a bird in the hand is worth
two in the bush or the grass isn't
really greener on the other side or
something like that so of course as I've
been telling you we are very closely
monitoring the polling data and it is
still quite tight we have a couple of
new poles uh Walker versus Warnock
Rafael Warnock is now winning by an
average of 3.3 there is a neutrophilger
poll that basically has this even with
Warnock plus one as insane as it is this
guy should be losing by 50. Walker
he's still in the race and so it is
going to take more to knock this guy out
of the race it will probably go until
the last minute on Election Day
But continuing to humiliate himself and
who thinks these press conferences are
good ideas we'll take a quick break and
be back after this yes right-wing media
fell for a black lives matter antifa
hoax we will talk about it next
follow us on social media interact with
the David packman show Community see
exclusive content See when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
Big Show announcements WE Post daily
find us on Reddit Twitter Instagram
Facebook Discord and tick tock
all right you may or may not remember
the story I'm about to talk about this
incident uh in question happened in
September of 2020. there was an incident
where there was BLM antifa Joe Biden
spray painted at a uh business and all
of the right-wing media even though the
entire thing stung to high heaven came
out to talk about how violent the left
is and how terrible and venteroristic
black lives matter and antifa are and we
have now learned from court documents
and a release from the District of
Minnesota district attorney of
Minnesota's office that it was all a
hoax it was all an insurance hoax so
let's start with the new document from
the U.S attorney's office from Minnesota
Brooklyn Center man pleads guilty to
insurance fraud after staging a
politically motivated arson attack uh oh
that's pretty interesting what happened
um according to court documents on
September 23rd of 2020 Dennis Mala 30
years old falsely reported to law
enforcement that someone lit his camper
on fire oh it was a camper not a uh yeah
not a business a lid is camper on fire
and that three unknown males were near
the home when he heard an explosion Mala
also reported his garage door was
vandalized with spray-painted graffiti
which said Biden 2020
BLM and an antifa symbol and that his
camper was targeted because it had a
trump 2020 flag on it the idea was this
was a political
incident in reality Mala started his own
property on fire and spray-painted the
graffiti on his own garage according to
court documents Mala submitted multiple
insurance claims seeking coverage for
the damage to his garage camper vehicles
and residents when the company denied
the claims he submitted a complaint
Mala also created and allowed others to
create multiple GoFundMe accounts to
benefit him and his family he submitted
more than three hundred thousand dollars
in fraudulent insurance claims got 61k
from his insurance company and 17 000
from donors via GoFundMe
he has now pleaded guilty to one count
of wire fraud sentencing will happen at
a later time
so how did we find out this was a hoax
well as it says in the release it was
investigated by the FBI and the Brooklyn
Center remember this Brooklyn Minnesota
Brooklyn Center Police Department
let's go back and look at how Ben
Shapiro and uh Laura Ingram talked about
this particular incident at the time
there's a story out of Minnesota
that began to get some traction today
and it was very disturbing
um and this was a
a homeowners who woke up to find that
their garage basically was on fire did
they really burn down they had a trump
they had a trump uh you know flag or
poster up and had been burned and then
Biden 2020
uh graffiti and the antifa symbol uh and
this this is Minnesota nice there's a
message being sent Ben by the far left
and I think people are beginning to see
that arsonist's behavior looting even
murder none of it's off the table right
well the fact is by the way murder what
are you talking about generic statements
about violence and looting being bad are
not going to cut it we all know that if
this were right Wingers were performing
this kind of violence Joe Biden would be
out there on the front lines proclaiming
the right-wing ideology was innately
linked to violence and cruelty but as
soon as it is left Wingers in his
Coalition who are out there harassing
people at restaurants or burning things
down or perhaps shooting police officers
as we saw in Louisville last night well
then the movement that they are linked
to the broader ideological movement they
are linked to he refuses to condemn it's
one thing to condemn generically
violence and looting I was told by the
way when Donald Trump did that back in
Charlottesville that wasn't enough he
had to specifically condemn one specific
ideology which by the way he kind of he
absolutely did actually yeah
so it was all a hoax and the of course
none of them are following up on it it
was actually an insurance hoax
perpetrated by an actual trumpist
because remember even though the BLM
Biden antifa stuff was fake in the sense
that it was done by the homeowner the
homeowner's Trump flag was real it was
really a trumpist homeowner now does
that mean all trumpists are Insurance
fraudsters of course it doesn't but look
at how the story was leveraged by Ben
Shapiro and Laura Ingram to make a
broader point in general leftists are
violent antifa is violent black lives
matter is violent and they are willing
to go even further using the fraudulent
and fake story of the spray paint
to say even murder isn't too much for
them well what do you what murder what
are you talking about what on Earth are
you talking about the real scary part is
that when the the Fox News audience sees
this they start to believe well if the
left is so violent against us then we
can be violent against them because it's
only fair even though the premise is a
fraudulent hoax for which someone has
now been convicted so
you'll never get the correction from
them obviously but at least I'm doing
what I can to make sure you know the
entire thing they made a big deal out of
it for multiple days back when it
happened the entire thing was a trumpist
hoax hey this is super interesting
Newsmax is talking about Tulsi gabbard
as Trump's running mate for 2024 and I
have to tell you
it makes a lot of sense it really does
so you might remember that yesterday
Tulsi gabbard on the first episode of
her podcast what what fortuitous timing
announced that she's leaving the
Democratic party now really for years
Tulsi had no business being associated
with the Democratic party she was a
um a contrarian reactionary with pseudo
populist right-wing messaging much more
aligned with Naga world than with any
Democrats that I know she now officially
has left the Democratic party and is
becoming an independent and here is Greg
Kelly on Newsmax saying what about tool
c as Trump's running mate Tulsi gabbard
she quit the Democrat party today and
did it in spectacular fashion oh the
former Democrat congresswoman from
Hawaii is now in by the way we looked at
the video by by spectacular fashion she
did it with conspiracy theories about
elitist cabals and false claims about
what the left believes independent and I
believe could very well will be a future
running mate for Donald Trump whoa all
right so she quit on the first episode
of her new podcast take a look
now I love our country our god-given
rights of Freedom life and Liberty that
are enshrined in our Constitution Bill
of Rights are what inspires me
all right she's just warming up you
realize though that statement about the
Constitution a reverence for our Bill of
Rights how this makes her Persona
non-grata in the Democrat Party this is
radical stuff for them actually her
completely reactionary conspiratorial
statements and false claims about
anti-white racism woke and an elitist
cabal are what make her not at home in
the Democratic party now I have to tell
you
it makes way more sense that she would
be Trump's running mate I mean think
about it they're on the same page about
oh uh the the left is all about being
against faith and against religion and
uh they want to be racist to white
people
it makes a ton of sense that she would
be Trump's running mate and that's why
we can tell it never really made sense
that she was a Democrat there was this
vague idea oh she's against regime
change Wars
uh okay
and that made her what special in some
way most people are against regime
change Wars when they agree about what
the regime change Wars are but there was
really nothing else that made her at all
interesting to the Democratic party or
as a Democrat and so I don't think she's
actually going to be Trump's running
mate but she would be much more at home
there uh as a Maga reactionary than she
has been in the Democratic party for a
very long time we got a ton of
voicemails yesterday about my interview
with my pillow CEO Mike Lindell I have
to tell you I struggled with how to
conduct that interview because he's so
shot out of a Canon and all over the
place
and a lot of people criticized my
handling of the interview here's one
caller who thought that I did okay
hi David this is Bonnie from Utah yes
and I just wanted to tell you that I
really enjoyed your conversation with
Mike pillow
I was actually quite impressed with him
he didn't seem quite as
shall we say anxious and sweaty
as he sometimes does
so maybe he switched to decaf who knows
maybe
I was impressed with your interaction
with him
and uh your degree of respect
and your ability to reel in the
conversation when he sort of was trying
to jump out of the crowd yeah so
um good job I enjoy uh your program and
I'm a 65 year old liberal Progressive
broad from Utah
so yeah it is a challenge but keep up
the good work guys you're doing great
well I really appreciate that there were
positive comments and negative comments
about the interview
um there were people who wrote and said
I didn't interrupt enough there were
people who wrote and said I interrupted
too much uh etc etc I do the best I can
and I think it went okay and uh
generating now by the way he did say
many things that weren't true like for
example one of the things pillows
obviously one of the things he said was
none of the judges that threw out
election challenges threw them out on
merits only on standing within minutes
of the interview posting someone emailed
me a judge in Wisconsin who threw out a
case based on the merits so it's it can
be difficult to have all the information
handy as the interview is going on and
that's one of the big challenges Sam
Harris whatever you think about Sam
Harris accurately describes the
difficulty with these interviews where
he says someone can you can only be so
prepared they can always find something
you're not familiar with they show up
and they make some statement about they
set a bunch of small fires and now you
have to figure out how to put each fire
out and it can be very difficult and
that certainly was a factor yesterday
we've got a great bonus show for you
today producer Pat is back no longer
under the weather we will talk about new
concerns about a PayPal draft leak we
will talk about the Uvalde Uvalde Uvalde
School District suspending its entire
police department we will talk about the
latest on self-driving cars which I
think you will find interesting and much
more get the bonus show by signing up at
joinpakman.com
foreign